Narrator: This is a scene
from "The Amazing Spider-Man."
This is from Marvel's "Luke Cage."
And this is a scene from "Joker."
Notice something similar?
They're all shot in the exact same place:
the 12th Avenue underpass in Harlem.
Samson Jacobson: When you stand
underneath Riverside Drive,
I mean, it is the classic
abandoned New York location
that everybody always wants.
Narrator: The underpass
is known for its viaduct,
an arching structure with a grandeur
filmmakers are drawn to.
Aaron Hurvitz: It gets a lot of play
because it is just a really
visually captivating space.
It gives this basically cascading overhang
of just metalwork.
Narrator: This is just one
of several New York filming locations
you see pop up again and
again in shows and movies.
We spoke with five location scouts
to find out why these spots
are in such high demand.
If you look closely at the prison scenes
in a bunch of New York movies,
you'll see these were all filmed
at Arthur Kill Correctional Facility.
This decommissioned
prison in Staten Island
has everything you could
ever need for a jail
or prison scene, from the barbed wire
and guard tower in front
to real cells inside.
It also comes with a lot of
space, with 70 acres of grounds
and these long stretches of hallway.
That helps for choreographing
action sequences.
It's that kind of facility,
and there aren't that
many, that lends itself
to having these really
long, unbroken takes,
like "Daredevil" season three.
12 or 13 minutes uncut
just moving through the entire space,
down the hallways, past the
cells, out to the front door.
Narrator: The location is
surprisingly versatile.
Malaika: Multiple cellblocks can look
like different prisons if you
didn't want to just be at one.
Bruno Barros: There are
sections that could work
as a hospital, and it's great because,
let's say you have to marry
two locations together
and those scenes don't fill a full day.
You can combine them into one day
and film it there, for example.
Narrator: The facility's giant parking lot
was even dressed up as
Afghanistan for "The Code."
Dramatic mystery scenes,
villain face-offs,
and wild car stunts have
all used this very backdrop:
the Brooklyn Navy Yard, a
vestige of industrial New York.
Brooklyn once had a busy
industrial waterfront,
but over the past few decades,
high-rise apartment complexes
and office buildings
have moved in and turned
the former manufacturing hub
much more residential.
That's why scouts return again
and again to this shipyard,
where 70,000 people once worked
before it closed down in 1966.
When everything is emptied
out, the abandoned docks
and hulking warehouses can
create an ominous look,
exactly what crime shows are after.
You want that, you know,
really industrial or,
"Oh, no, somebody's getting
murdered on the docks at night!"
Great place to go to.
Narrator: Bodies have been dumped
at this dry dock in multiple shows.
The amount of open space makes it possible
to execute wild stunts,
like when "Daredevil" blew
up a boat on the docks.
Malaika: The end of the
first "John Wick" movie,
there was a car chase,
and then a car crashed into this dry dock.
You know, dropped into it.
Narrator: Many filmmakers
focus on the grit of the city,
but some scenes call for a more
buttoned-up New York setting,
like this one that pops up again and again
in scenes involving business
or government meetings.
Manhattan has plenty of office spaces,
but many are on extremely high floors,
which means the lighting
very much depends on the sky.
Rather than relying on natural
light from the windows,
the filmmakers need to
control the lighting.
Then you can basically shoot
it any which way you want
and have it look always the same.
Narrator: But the higher
the office spaces are,
the more difficult to get lights into.
That's what makes this spot prime.
It's an office on the third floor
of the Brooklyn Public Library
with big windows that crews
can pass lights through,
and because it's on a reachable floor,
they can do it without getting
a big Condor lift involved.
The office also has a
versatile mid-century design
that can work across many decades,
from modern business
dramas like "Billions"
to period pieces like "The
Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
A lot of the most famous
subway scenes are shot
at one specific station:
Hoyt-Schermerhorn.
The reason this spot is so popular?
Well, filming authentic subway scenes
comes with huge challenges.
Sometimes you're at the whim of the MTA,
and things can change.
We had that happen for "In the Heights."
They had to reroute their trash trains,
and essentially their trash trains
had to come through our set.
Narrator: Crews are less likely to run
into these logistical
problems if they film
at tracks that are no longer in use,
like the one at Hoyt-Schermerhorn.
It's a working station,
but with one deactivated
platform among three active ones.
It's a place where we know we can film
during regular business hours.
Narrator: Signage can turn it into
basically any other subway stop,
like in this scene from
"Coming to America."
When Lisa enters the station,
it's labeled as Van Wyck Boulevard,
but if you look closely,
you'll see it's actually Hoyt.
The giveaway is those
blue and yellow tiles
with a circled L in the middle,
remnants of what was once
one of Brooklyn's biggest
department stores,
Loeser's, which stood
where Hoyt does today.
Then, when Lisa exits the train,
the station's labeled Sutphin,
but this was also filmed at Hoyt.
Recognize this bar?
It's appeared in everything
from TV shows like "Gotham"
to movies like "The Kitchen."
For scenes set in dive bars
and shadowy back rooms,
directors like Martin Scorsese
often want the real deal.
Brooklyn's Irish Haven
has kept its tile floors
and wood paneling mostly
unchanged since 1964,
when it was a favorite
spot for ironworkers
to unwind after work.
There's a pool table,
dartboard, and jukebox.
It has also just this great,
seasoned New York look to it.
You don't have to change
too much when you go there.
Narrator: The no-frills
exterior and dimly lit interior
are well suited to gritty
settings like Gotham,
and the classically divey
setting can stand in
for other cities, too, not just New York.
The bar and pool table are
famous for these scenes
in the Boston-set "The Departed."
When you see New York in a movie,
you might see a scene like this or this:
a dark, seedy alleyway
filled with graffiti,
shuttered apartment windows,
and old fire escapes.
But in reality, New York
doesn't really have alleyways,
which means dozens of famous
scenes have been filmed
in this exact spot to
get that gritty look.
One reason so many scripts
call for New York scenes
to take place in alleys
is, well, Hollywood.
Aaron: The writing for most
projects takes place in LA.
When you go to LA,
there's alleys everywhere.
Narrator: New York was designed according
to the grid system, with
little to no space for alleys.
The real estate is so valuable
that we just didn't leave space for it.
Samson: If they're envisioning LA alleys,
probably not gonna find them.
But there are other types of alleys
that are smaller and tighter.
Narrator: Like Cortlandt
Alley, which might be
the most used filming
location in all of Manhattan.
Eric: That is an alley that
gives you just about everything.
It's fire escapes, it's graffiti.
Narrator: Many of the apartment windows
have these big, decades-old shutters,
which adds to the alley's aesthetic.
Crews can put lights inside the windows
of the apartments above.
I've paid people in the
same apartment buildings
for lighting positions looking
in the same exact spots that,
you know, "Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles" shot in as well.
Narrator: The location's use goes beyond
just gritty scenes.
Take this wholesome scene in
"Annie," which Eric worked on.
The team used Cortlandt Alley
to create a path for this chase sequence,
adding trash and boxes as obstacles.
Little nooks in the
alleyway served as spots
for the dog trainers
to hide during filming.
Since Cortlandt Alley
is owned by the city,
it's cheaper to film there.
As it's one of the very
few actual public alleys,
it gets used all the time.
Narrator: So much that sometimes
it's put in what's called the "hot zone."
In New York City, when
something's been filmed too much
and the residents are unhappy
with the impact it has,
the mayor's office will put
something on the hot zone,
and that means that there's
a sort of moratorium
on filming until they take it off there.
Narrator: Cortlandt
Alley has stayed looking
more or less the same for decades,
but in much of New York,
things are always changing.
These steps in "Joker"?
They were actually the
director's second choice.
Todd Phillips initially requested
this menacing set of stairs
from "American Gangster."
And when I went to go visit it,
it had gotten a whole makeover.
Brand-new concrete, little cute trees.
It had been power-washed
of all of its graffiti and grit.
Narrator: After visiting 25
to 30 different step streets,
Aaron tracked down this one,
which had exactly what
they were looking for.
It brought drama.
Aaron: In terms of the length
and steepness of the stairs,
kind of confined and narrow,
it hit all the marks,
and it had that great view
just off from the top
looking into the city
that really worked for us as well.
Narrator: The spot
became instantly iconic,
showing that while the face of
the city is always changing,
New York will always be a
great place to shoot movies.